in late last year I started watching a
YouTube channel called playing with
power MTG it's primarily a cedh channel
short for competitive EDH and though I
hadn't played high power EDH much at all
let alone competitively the spectacle of
it all along with the quality of the
editing and the voiceover kept me
watching the first five or so games I
watched were really cool you know seeing
all these expensive cards I'd never
played with these Cutthroat plays these
hyper optimized decks but then gradually
I started to notice something it seemed
like all of the cards were the same like
the ways the next gain Mana are the same
and the way they draw cards are the same
and the ways they end the game are the
same and the ways they stop other people
from ending the game are also the same
this intrigued me and with this
observation I did what any normal person
would do I looked up the top 10 cedh
decks and a popular deck list for each
and I compared the lists to see how many
cards they shared all told there were 20
cards shared by all 10 decks with nine
of these being lands five being an rocks
four being counter spells and two being
card draw enchantments there were also a
number of cards shared by all Decks that
play a particular color such as doite
extortionist silence and demonic tutor
most interesting of all were the wions
with the two dominant ones being
theorical demonic consultation run in
seven of the 10 decks and underworld
breach brain freeze Lion's eye Diamond
run in six of the 10 decks only two
decks ran neither of these those being
kinan which generally wins through an
infinite Mana combo followed by playing
out its entire library and sis which
generally wins through a family of
flicker based combos that it can tutor
out with its Commander with this
exercise out of the way I had
established that yes there is quite a
lot of card overlap in cedh but why is
this exactly and what effects does it
have on the format the first reason that
there's so much overlap is simple at a
competitive level players want to run
cards that are as fast as flexible and
as efficient as possible when you're
playing a chance-based card game where
you might have access to only a small
portion of your deck at a time every
draw needs to do as much as possible
this is also the case for other
competitive Magic the Gathering formats
but EDH is different from Modern or
Legacy in that it's 100 cards and
Singleton this means that for a given
type of card you need to play a lot more
different copies of that type of card
than in a 60 card format if we look at
modern Merk tide it's running 9ish
counter spells in the main board the MTG
goldfish list contains contains four
copies of counter spell two copies of
spell Pierce and a single copy each of
spell snare Stern scolding and subtlety
a similarly interactive cedh deck will
often end up running 12 or more
differently named counter spells while
there will usually be a short list of
potential meta pivots in a format like
modern or Legacy in cedh you're already
playing the maximum allowed number of
your seventh e8th and Ninth favorite
counter spells because you have to this
effect applies to most other areas too
particularly ramp draw and Wing
conditions ramp is the most homogeneous
fast rocks rituals one Mana dorks and
lands that tap for multiple Mana or King
here though decks usually want rocks
badly enough to run a couple two Mana
rocks as well draw usually ends up being
things that abuse either the multiplayer
aspect of EDH or the 40 life aspect
ristic study Mystic rora and esper
Sentinel are ubiquitous and adnasium is
so powerful that it blurs the line
between draw spell and one card wincon
speaking of winon
these tend to be overwhelmingly combo
based underworld breach and thasus
Oracle based combos tend to be by far
the strongest available due to their low
investment and resiliency and most cedh
decks contain either one of these or a
combo directly tied to their commander
in some way this doesn't necessarily
mean that CDH decks are boring in how
they win but it does mean that when you
look at somebody's commander and the
colors they're playing you'll often be
able to immediately guess one or more of
their win conditions in addition to the
previously mentioned reasons a big
contributing factor to why there's so
much card overlap between different
decks can be seen right at the outset
looking at the top 10 decks these decks
run a lot of colors there are three
five-color decks two four-color decks
four three-color decks and a single
two-color deck fundamentally this comes
down to the fact that cedh is an
essentially budget lless format which
allows for very good Mana bases at very
little gameplay expense to the player
barring non basic hate this paired with
the singlet to nature of the format
reducing the number of efficient options
available in each color means that decks
will generally want as many colors as
possible and only choose to run fewer
when there's a great card in the command
Zone to make up for that loss of
efficiency this can be seen in all of
the partner Commander pairings that
people go with are vile Smasher The
Fierce and ton of the blood sour
insanely powerful cards no they're
pretty mediocre the reason they're
popular is that they let a player run a
commander they actively like such as
timna or Malcolm and add to it a couple
colors they want to have plus the
utility of having an extra playable card
in a pinch the result of this is that a
lot of meta decks end up being four to
five color piles of the best cards in
the format these decks can be quite
interesting on their own mind you as
decks with quality synergies and
flexible play paths that better use
these premium cards will outperform
decks whose construction could be
described as a jumbled mish mash of
assorted and sunry good stuff but the
difference between those two decks can
come down to a small handful of cards
that the deck then tutors for rendering
these differences subtle on the scale of
a deck list in addition the realm of
what's possible is limited by the sheer
speed flexibility and efficiency
required by The Format value engines and
windc cons must be some combination of
fast explosive consistent resilient and
Compact and if a deck game plan doesn't
satisfy enough of these conditions the
deck likely won't be able to keep up and
pull off winds
this to me might be the biggest issue as
you climb to the highest power levels of
EDH the range of possible decks you can
build and plays you can make contracts
further and further it's at this point I
can hear some of you saying who does
this casual EDH YouTuber think he is to
complain about cedh or maybe you were
saying that earlier when I was talking
about comparing the top 10 decks or
maybe when you saw the thumbnail before
clicking on the video regardless I hear
you and you know what I asked myself the
same question while brainstorming for
this video so I downloaded cockatrice
and played a bunch of cedh games and
between bullying strangers on the
internet with woda and conversations
I've had with various people who play
cedh several things about the format
beyond the decks themselves have become
clear to me and a lot of them are
actually pretty interesting first of all
there's generally no rule zero
conversation because the whole idea is
to be as powerful as possible within the
confines of the EDH format this is nice
in and of itself as a big challenge I've
had in casual EDH is the pregame
struggle of putting together a game
that's actually fun for everybody at the
table an extension of this is that
there's not much salt at cedh tables
compared to Casual the whole idea of the
format is that everything is on the
table so when somebody rushes a combo or
staes the table into Oblivion nobody
gets particularly bothered about it
other than maybe about the fact they
weren't able to stop it the social
aspects that make casual EDH fun to me
are still present threat analysis table
coordination against the scary foe
trying to Curry favor with a potential
ally but a lot of the more negative
social aspects the ones that come from
the friction of players having different
play Styles and objectives are
eliminated in addition another cool
thing about the culture of cedh is the
proxy question in the sense that it's
basically a solved issue the goal of the
format is to play as powerfully as
possible so the community is generally
very proxy friendly and some circles are
proxy friendly to the point where not
choosing to proxy fast Mana or dual
lands that would make your deck better
is considered kind of weird this stands
in contrast to Casual EDH where on the
one hand you'll encounter people who get
offended by the whole idea of proxying
and on the other hand you'll get awkward
situations where somebody proxies a
bunch of Power Cards for their janky
mid-range deck in order to crush the
janky mid-range decks of their friends
having this issue solved so gracefully
in CDH with the answer arising naturally
from the format's culture of everybody
getting the chance to play EDH as
powerfully as they possibly can is nice
with all this context in mind I think
it's worth going back to reexamine the
premise of this video I started this
video with an analysis of the top 10
cedh decks and I think it's important to
talk about where that list came from EDH
top 16 compiles cedh tournament data and
ranks decks according to the number of
top 16 placements these are the Decks
that consistently show up and place
highly at tournaments and on a macro
scale they do represent the format on
some level but the tournaments these
decks are pulled from aren't just the
these 10 decks mashing against each
other in pod after pod and beneath the
surface there's actually a lot of really
interesting stuff happening here I'm
pretty unqualified to talk about those
things as somebody whose cedh career
spans a couple dozen or so cockatrice
games with random people on the internet
so I'm going to pull in somebody who is
more qualified hey I'm the trinket Mage
and I've been playing in CDH tournaments
since 2016 Alex is 100% correct those
top 10 decks are the most common builds
you will see but there is something to
be said about off-meta builds I've
exclusively been playing jce frce
Prodigy at tournaments since 2016 I just
love manual storm on paper model blue
seems unoptimal due to the lack of
options my list for example does not run
th's Oracle so I'm able to win through
hate like hushbringer or torper orb that
people commonly play against Oracle
decks and since basically nobody plays
Jace with any regularity when I go to a
new store or play at a magic Fest nobody
knows what my wincons are or how the
combos work I've won plenty of games
simply because my opponents lacked
matchup knowledge plus your pet deck can
be tuned to be more effective in your
personal local meta for me I recently
included wipe away so I can more
forcefully remove permanence without
having to worry about countermagic since
my local meta is very blue Farm heavy so
don't be afraid to try some lower tier
cedh decks you can still get great
results from an off-meta build as the
trick Major's choice to run wipe away
suggests interaction Suites can be a
real Divergence point in card choice in
addition there are different Decks that
will thrive in different metas some
decks are better against decks which
execute their game plan as quickly as
possible some decks are better against
slower decks which try to be flexible
and grind value and others are better
against Stacks heavy decks depending on
the composition of decks played at a
given place at a given time it can be
highly effective to run Decks that
wouldn't normally be considered top
contenders as a final point in this
section I think it's interesting to
think about some of the weirder
implications of the cedh meta ones that
specifically derive from the
predictability of top decks prer grasp
is a card commonly played in adnasium
decks because as long as there's at
least one similar deck at the table is
effectively a grim tutor with upside
that also pulls a pivotal card from an
opposing deck nemonic betrayal is an
even more powerful example of this idea
since decks often share so many cards in
a lot of games it effectively becomes a
better yog moth will as a third example
ragavan effectively offers a down
sideless Outpost Siege effect it would
suck to Exile a demonic consultation or
underworld breach off the top of your
own library on a turn you're not ready
to play it but when it's your opponent's
Library you're gambling with hitting a
card like that is all upside since
either you can go for the win or you can
just let your opponent's win Outlet go
to permanent Exile you will also see
cards that get put into a deck for one
purpose but a given situation might call
for a different one Bergie a great Mana
generator can instead be cast as a draw
engine if a player really needs a way to
dig through their Library during a given
game and a famously spicy part of cedh
is the forbidden tutor wherein a player
uses demonic consultation a popular
combo piece for its original purpose as
a highly risky tutor I find these sorts
of use cases really fun as they turn the
ostensibly Bland card diversity of some
of ced's top decks on its head inventing
new use cases for existing Staples
this video has been a bit of a journey
because painting a picture of a whole
format is an inherently challenging task
I'd encourage anybody who is interested
to give cedh a try since it's a pretty
unique MTG experience it's also just
about as proxy friendly as EDH gets
especially if you use a program like
cockatrice where not KNN in the cards is
already built in my feelings about CED
are mixed because as a format it has
some pretty cool attributes individual
decks are stuffed with interesting plays
and synergies and often represent the
Pinnacle of a given archetype games are
fast-paced complex and exciting with
battles for the stack often containing
five or more spells and abilities and
yet there is a sort of cookie cutter
blandness to it when it comes to card
diversity and more interesting options
for draw Mana generation and closing out
a game will often simply lack the raw
efficiency to be fully viable for these
reasons among others I personally don't
enjoy cedh as much as casual but I think
an understanding of the cedh format can
give a lot of insights into how to have
more fun playing casual as far as deck
building goes I think an idea a lot of
people take from cedh is that playing
the best combos will make your deck
better and while this is true in the
sense that it might make you win more
games it's not a useful fact for having
fun with casual EDH unless you like
those combos like actually like them
beyond the novelty value and unless you
can find opponents who enjoy playing at
a table with those combos CDH decks have
game plans that looking to follow but a
decent portion of games end with a combo
being pushed through either earlier than
people can interact or at an opportune
moment when the table is depleted of
resources to respond with this is not to
say that this is a bad Dynamic and
indeed it invites lots of interesting
strategic and deck building choices but
these choices naturally come down to how
to win a competitive game of Magic the
Gathering more so then how to optimize a
game plan in the traditional sense and
i' wager that following a cohesive game
plan to to its conclusion is what a lot
of people find fun about casual
Commander to me the more applicable
lesson to be taken from cedh is the card
quality filter running cards that are
more flexible and more efficient cards
that consistently feel at least decent
to draw will improve your deck basically
minimize dead draws and if cards rely on
other cards to be good their effect
needs to be very strong to make up for
the amount of time they'll sit dead in
hand what an efficient or flexible card
means will differ deck to deck but
prioritizing these things will improve
your deck's overall functionality
finally I think cedh can also serve as a
lesson for why casual EDH can be
difficult to have fun playing sometimes
cedh games are generally friendlier and
less salty than casual EDH games in
large part because player expectations
are aligned from the outset of the game
in the sense that everybody is there to
win at all costs and deck power levels
are affixed at the most concrete value
as high as possible this is certainly
not to say that playing at that power
level is the way to have fun playing EDH
but it is to say that aligning
expectations and power levels before the
game is a step that exists in casual EDH
an unsolved problem that is presented
anytime four people walk up to a table
to play a game of Commander EDH is a
social game and the way to have more fun
is by talking to your opponents more
both during the game and before the game
even
starts thanks for watching and big shout
out to the trinket Mage for helping out
with this video a link to his channel is
in the description if you want to go
check his stuff out I also have an
announcement which is that the patreon
deck I randomly selected to be reviewed
next week is Grill control so that
should be cool and fun all right bye now